did you see this lizard thing someone
explained it to me she was like
what will you explain it
so there was there's a tick tock I just
got sent before I came in here but this
girl is saying there's a lawsuit against
lizzo from people that worked with her
backup dancers and stuff they said she
would body shame the backup dancers in
which way
I'm assuming he was they were too fat
just because they're dancers and dancers
but if you want a dancer to be fat
that's going to be tough I I figured it
was the opposite way oh you girls are
too skinny skinny and she's known for
being big yeah but even then you can't
wait shame right that's your whole thing
oh I just think it's a funny thing to
see the reverse happening yeah I think
it was they didn't say which side
um and then also
he like put dancers in on color like
people that work for uncomfortable
situations like I think she took him to
a sex show with like nude people and
they were doing like sexual things and
then she kind of really pressured one
girl into she like had everybody touch
the breasts on one of these models or
whatever and then one person really
didn't want to but she just like kept
yelling at them like mocking me but like
getting the whole crowd to make fun of
her and like chant like just do it or
whatever and then she had to do and
there's a couple other allegations isn't
there one like she forced one to eat a
banana they support someone to eat the
banana that was in the [__] yeah that
might be one of them but also it's
hilarious that like that's a punishment
for her eating Health
you've been bad you should have some
fruits and vegetables
yeah at the club lizzo began inviting
cast members to take turns touching the
new performers catching dildos from
performers vaginas and eating bananas
protruding from the performers
lizzo then turned her attention to Miss
Davis and began to Crusher Miss Davis to
touch the breast of one of the nude
women
so that's from the article
so apparently she's bringing all these
people to this like place where these
sexual acts are happening in Amsterdam
and they don't want to do it and she's
like encouraging them to to take part
yeah and I think she wasn't they were
none of this seems like a big deal if
it's a regular person but if it's lizzo
whose entire career is built on a moral
High Ground apparently some dancers want
like uh 50 of their pay during whatever
period like they weren't working and
then she said that was disrespectful she
said I'll give you 25 and they were like
it's disrespectful for you to be gonna
ask for 50. and again that's normal
business practice but I think if you're
lizzo your entire career is built on
being morally Superior
you're talented she's talented
yeah
how fat fat shame me I'm healthy is that
her thing you didn't know lizard was
proud of being fat I thought that people
just called her fat and then her
reaction was like yeah I'm fat
I think she's very proud of being fat
and don't shame me for being fat and
like I'm an incredible I don't even
remember we played positive and all that
time yeah we had a video where she uh
was like working out and she's like you
can judge me for my my body all you want
to but I'm healthy and I work out and
then you clocked it it was just her
training outfits the same day and it was
one workout but she made it seem like
she was working out like seven days a
week or whatever
yeah that's the problem with just having
a moral High Ground like if you have a
Public Image just lead off with like hey
I'm kind of an [__] that's all you
got to do it's so simple and then if
you're nice people you're like dude that
guy's not an [__] he's awesome yeah
yeah why can't we except
stars are often going to be creepy and
female stars are often going to be
[__] and if they're not hey man God
bless you yeah God bless you good for
you yeah just expecting them to be
Angelic is you're always going to be
disappointed yeah and the ones who build
a career off of that never gonna they're
always gonna disappoint you first yeah
all right guys we're gonna take a break
real quick because you all know about
freeze pipe you know that it is the best
way to smoke uh certain substances that
you might want to smoke that are legal
in some states and not legal in other
states but anyway if you don't want to
burn your lungs you want to cough up a
storm use your freeze pipe well now they
got this little guy right here you know
it goes right in there a blunt maybe a
vape pen you just stick it right in
there 20 minutes it freezes that's all
it takes 20 minutes not even an hour
anymore 20 minutes it will give you the
much needed icy glycerin coldness that
you get with the other products but it
takes 20 minutes so no more burning
lungs no more coughing unnecessarily
nice smooth cool sensation fills your
chest and makes you feel great so say
goodbye to horse smoke and coughing
attacks by shopping the smoothest pipes
bubblers bongs and dab rings at the
freeze pipe.com and use it called flagon
for 15 off your entire order and again
make sure you cop this the glycerin
blunt tip it's a fantastic product I'm
sure of it everything else they make is
dope this just came out 20 minutes
anyway that is the freezepipe.com and
use the code flagrant so you get your 15
off shop today and start fighting fire
with ice now let's get back to the show
what about like the Taylor Swift's
because I feel like she's not
like preachy but she does live a super
clean image I don't I think she presents
herself as being a lot nicer than she
really is she really presents herself as
like a door next girl next door like I'm
so sweet and all these men have done
this and it's like yo you're a [__]
billionaire there's I'm pretty sure she
grew up like very rich you're not like
some pristine super nice person there's
no way yeah politically neutral yeah
yeah I think what happens you just have
to be politically neutral yeah I mean I
I don't I just think what happens with
famous people in general is like if
you're not a fan
you hate them it's very rare that people
are like wildly successful and the
people who are not fans are just neutral
on them like with Taylor Swift it's
super fans biggest tour ever people ever
and then everyone else is kind of like
Ugh she just takes men and writes songs
about them and uses them and plays the
victim all the time ah [__] that [__]
and I think that's just a natural
function of human beings like
criticizing those that are very
successful if we don't understand our
success their success so I think they've
just got to kind of deal with it I think
Taylor's done a good job though for how
famous she is yeah she like it seems
like lizzo gets more criticism with a
fraction of the fame
yeah probably that's true and I think
that that's also a function of this like
fat is healthy movement and she's become
like a spokesperson for it maybe without
even wanting to be yeah like
she she knows she's fat the only
opportunity she has she knows you're not
gonna lose the weight so she's got to go
no I'm great I'm awesome like you get
defensive and you need to reject that
and then the body positivity movement
exalts her and goes you're a [__]
hero and now she's like [__] I'm the fat
[__] is healthy girl now [__] he used
to be a dell and she was like I'm out
I'm out she got skinny real quick yeah
so
maybe that's the best weight loss
programs like hey you're the face of
body positivity and then you're like
that's really insulting I'm out here
that's all that's also varying something
yeah
we should start that as a weight loss
program that'd be awesome which is
basically like you just find people who
want to lose weight and be like hey
we're gonna make a website saying you
are the new face of body parts you're
beautiful you're beautiful you're the
most beautiful fat person that's ever
existed we're a publicist and we're
going to take over we're going to put
you on news you're going to do News
interviews finest fat female in all the
lands yeah exactly the bravest woman in
America
and then we're gonna flip them that's
funny that's brilliant we'll make a lot
of money doing that yeah I love this
right yeah that's what I'm saying that's
a good scheme and it's a great weight
loss program for America yeah you don't
want to be the next face of fat [__]
yeah we're coming for you yeah we're
like Anonymous for fat people yeah yeah
this is awesome dude you see the Nathan
Fielder one did I tell you guys about
this yeah dude this guy has some fun
[__] dude he gets a woman who works in a
law office she's like I really want to
lose weight he's like all right here's
what we're gonna do we're gonna take a
picture of you holding a paper that has
a swastika drawn on it and you're gonna
be like basically like partially naked
and you're gonna have a letter in it
that's like I hate Jews her boss that
works at the law firm is a Jewish guy
she said okay we're gonna take this
picture we're gonna put it into an email
and it's going to be emailed to your
boss on February 1st of next year
unless you lose 40 pounds by then
and it's already locked in the email I'm
the only person that can stop it so go
ahead and then every day she wakes up
and she's like
my boss is gonna see this horrifying
photo of me do you basically
blackmailing yourself into losing weight
I love it and this guy's so funny man
every day she wakes up she misses it by
like half a pound no it gets sent to him
and then she has to have a meeting and
they film it and she's like so I was
doing this TV show with this guy and he
told me it would be funny if I did this
and he's like I don't understand
and that's the whole thing
yeah she's in jail now for a hickey no I
I don't know I don't think I've seen
Dumb Starbucks yeah it's so good dude
that's blackmail yourself we need to
watch this have you seen dump Starbucks
it's so good miles go there's a YouTuber
called struthless who did that he
basically said like the worst [__] you
could say and he's like if I don't run a
marathon this goes live in like two
weeks or something wow or a month or
whatever and he says he put it like post
it he doesn't have access to it whatever
and then he was like yeah I ran the
marathon I almost killed himself had to
go to the hospital or something wow
anything you want to do oh I gotta write
this script I gotta [__] lose weight
whatever I have a tweet scheduled with
some crazy [__] in it
there you go miles give us some path of
the only questioning right now uh my
question for you guys is uh in order to
keep your career dreams alive if you had
to work any shitty jobs you know in
order to make ends meet maybe if you
have some old job shitty work stories
I'm curious what those might be
my follow-up question is show it to you
on the Kersey D episode talked about his
pops filming all his old games so I'm
curious when you guys are going to put a
little hoop mixtape together oh we got
one that's all I got though appreciate
y'all